the nintendo switch drops next year but  it seems like we're learning about more  and more games every day I'm Tony and  this is your third party game spot news  update to independent games have been  confirmed for nintendo's new console the  first is seasons of heaven as revealed  by French site game blog this 2018 game  is based on a French novel about an  autistic boy named yawn and his dog ani  the other game called the sacred hero  already has a teaser trailer out but we  really don't know much about it yet from  the teaser we can at least see a few  different environments Nintendo has a  big switch presentation planned for  January 12 so tuned and then to learn  more about the consoles price specs and  launch lineup we'll have all the latest  up on gamespot and for all the biggest  nintendo news you're already in the  right place  you